hello welcome to this video playing hmm
yeah something yeah so using year with a
ch3 hmm very early create sits that's
really early
I've never seen this is actual water and
I was wondering if there's something
maybe I should have played Bishop e3
actually to make 'if I've kind of
questionable it would have been quite
interesting actually boo me I shouldn't
play Bishop e3 Bishop is also probably
better there hmm now a tough position we
was afore okay wow so be should be 393
create this stuff
of course played instantly as they tend
to do so if I go let's say G for what is
happening here cheek skin TX Queen five
that's very very risky it's very very
risky for me but I mean it's probably
the only way to try to try to do
something here probably far too risky
but anyway I think you will take what
does he have something else 25 is the
move that worries me now
25 is threatening Queen g3 and the crew
and the night and the move like 92 looks
wrong somehow my king would have to is
super exposed really don't like the
scanner of exposed King positions yeah
took him a while but he he found this
move yeah he thought yes Bishop takes a
5 this is a big issue not now I think
but hmm you can probably just go Knight
f6 no acres of the piece doesn't even
it's not even necessary okay so as Queen
III in the position
I can do this let's cover step bishop
and i still have g two
yeah I really don't like defending such
a position but objectively speaking I
think why this was probably in Jack and
probably winning actually don't think
that this can be enough compensation
instead of course White has I have tons
of ways to to to screw this up and I'm
pretty good with that Oh what the heck
does that mean I completely flooded my
desk with water pretty pretty happy that
he's not playing quickly so that I can
take care of my spilled water okay age 6
plate I could just take on f4 to trade
stuff but then it's just an exchange
let's just drop back where's he going
with this Queen takes here I guess let's
let centralized and go from there what
is he going for my bishop de for in this
case so maybe here
root g 1 king h2 would be cool and why
does attacking
yeah I'll play that pretty much
regardless of what is doing this one
threatens not much rookie to in some
cases
k not sure if that was a was a good move
or not cannot go up g one now it's a bit
of a shame
mmm it's a bit of a shame
want to go bishop t for trying to trade
some things time warning
okay i think in general oh no not nuts
hablan de h2 taking here they're
probably not
I'd take you too long here by far Queen
g6 King f1 taking too long position is
winning of class but 29 seconds still
plenty on room to screw it up
just for simplicity sake check check an
ID f6 also was pretty strong check and
check black resigns yeah I think I did a
decent enough job them hmm now the way i
mean this this is certainly certainly
okay for black I mean that King position
is just I mean it should be out at least
okay for him so the engine gives this
and gives black an edge okay says he
knows the channel
yeah although the pre interesting game
and here I really had my doubts so the
engine just gives this and says blankets
check basically winning check Jim
chechik this is pretty awful check yeah
that's awful Black is getting yet
another pawn and this is just too much
just too much I came so that was the
point and here i don't think that this
is enough i aged 6 was even better okay
Shatner okay no the engine and confirms
that my move was also okay I probably
didn't play it the best around here but
I feel 00 rook takes e2 was winning for
blackjack I mean know this move yeah
this is the kind of move that you let
stuff to play wow that's a great point
Queen f2 qui g6 King age to look II to
as the point wow if I take checkmate
it's made Wow and here yeah I'm winning
yeah 95 was even clearer I didn't what
did I saw that I thought the check is
awkward but now here okay yeah that's
winning you know and this is me at least
the game and continued some somewhat i
can guarantee i'm winning by position at
least but time wise it was still kind of
kind of shaky okay hope you like the
game thanks for watching